time Santa's elves need a drink after a
hard day of building toys in the
workshop Rocky is showing us the
Silverton casino's Holiday Bar where
they will feel right at home
whether you're a good Elf or a bad elf
you are invited and welcomed here at the
Silverton Casino for bad elf the pop-up
bar here taking over the Shady Grove
Lounge now what was the inspiration
behind the decorations this year we
started with the idea of what if we
invited the bad elves uh to decorate our
Shady Grove lounge and uh so we've we've
got uh we've got a few dozen uh elves
here all throughout uh uh in they're all
uh in different uh different points of
Mischief different points of mission can
you name a few of those points of
Mischief I'm curious uh you know what
they've they've gone a little crazy uh
but they've been invented a whole new
bar menu and we've also invited uh
people to send their own elves here okay
so their own Elf on the Shelf at home if
you know they're done with the task of
being the elf on the shelf and they're
retiring right the idea is that we
should have a great place for our elves
on the shelves to retire so uh uh we we
sent out uh word earlier this year and
people didn't mailing them in and as we
get them in we we put them up you can
also bring them down and we'll buy you a
free drink so you bring in your Elf on
the Shelf and you get a free cocktail
absolutely name some of those special
holiday cocktails on the menu we've got
uh the bad uh the bad elf butter beer uh
we've got a grinch cocktail uh we've got
a spicy uh apple cider that's my
favorite and uh we've got Graham Central
shot all kinds of things to get you in
the holiday Moon all right also to get
you in the holiday mood our holiday
themed games after those drinks you
might want to you know maybe play these
games before the drinks because they
require a little brain power yeah we've
got the bad off experience uh which uh
uh allows you to uh uh play a game and
you can win a prize wow what would be
the prize uh it's dinner for two at our
Steakhouse okay all right for the bad
Health experience you can either walk up
you know just as a regular bar or you
can make a reservation in advance if you
want the full experience absolutely it's
called the bad elf experience uh and and
one level the bad of self-experience
even includes an hour of bottomless
cocktails oh okay so it's bad bad dur
and baddest which one are you all right
again this is here at the Silverton
Casino through January 2nd so come on
down